concernant les salaires vous savez quand
on est patron de pme
on vit avec ses salariés on les voit
tous les jours ils nous voient grandir
en tant que chef d'entreprise quand on
les accompagne depuis de nombreuses
années et nous aussi on les voit grandir
dans l'entreprise lorsqu'on les prend
dès l'apprentissage
on aimerait bien souvent les récompenses
et mieux que nous ne pouvons le faire
pourquoi parce que c'est le client qui
finalement met la pression sur
l'entreprise
on a deux obligations de résultat
lorsque nous sommes chef d'entreprise on
doit une obligation résultat vis-à-vis
de son client pour servir une commande
sur laquelle est bien il faut assurer ce
qu'on a vendu en qualité en quantité en
délais et en même temps on a une
obligation vis-à-vis de son entreprise
où il faut équilibrer les recettes et
les dépenses
et là bien évidemment la partie humaine
les salaires les hommes c'est très
important
et quand vous faites pas beaucoup de
marge eh bien les récompenses et ça
vient tout de suite compliqué regardez
par exemple
l'exemple de la prime que propose le
gouvernement qu'on appelle la prime
mâcon mais c'est plutôt la prime patron
parce que c'est c'est le chef
d'entreprise qui décide ou pas de la
donner eh bien on aimerait tellement
beaucoup d'entreprises aimerait
tellement pouvoir l'a versé à ceux de
nos collaborateurs qui ont continué à
travailler pendant cette période de
confinement mais lorsque votre modèle
économique est en train de tourner à
l'envers
à savoir que vos recettes n'équilibre
pas vos dépenses eh bien vous ne pouvez
pas les récompenser et donc vouloir
augmenter les salaires
et bien c'est tout simplement pouvoir
augmenter entre guillemets la marche des
entreprises et ce que nous avons tout le
temps réclamé à la cpmc que l'argent qui
reste dans l'entreprise
et bien soit bénéficiaire d'un niveau de
fiscalité inférieur par rapport à
l'argent qui sort de l'entreprise
je parle entre autres des dividendes
c'est à dire que ça permettrait de
muscler et de type de capitaliser les
petites entreprises
alors bien évidemment il faudrait
plusieurs années mais ça permettrait en
tout cas de faire partager la richesse
créée au plus grand nombre et en
priorité par les collaborateurs
[Musique]